[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander as the
executive director here at the long now
foundation thank you all for coming out
tonight as many of you know we often do
a long short before each of these talks
a short film that exemplifies long term
thinking on the theme of the evenings
talk tonight the idea is to provide a
bit of a bookend to to tonight's talk in
that these rice fields in or rice
terraces in the northern part of the
Philippines have been continuously
farmed for over 2,000 years so it's a
good example of some of the oldest rice
farming that's still going on today
as we talk about some of the newest
later on thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from Laura
now I got a drone for Christmas and
that's what happens to your mind when
you can take your eye up in the sky like
that the last time somebody dramatically
increased the productivity of food crops
now you got the Nobel Peace Prize for it
that was Norman Borlaug just a few
decades ago with the Green Revolution
and basically new varieties of wheat and
corn so this can be pretty consequential
and in the kind of time frame that we
just saw here people have been working
really hard to grow rice for 2,000 plus
years and if we can get easier and
better the next 2,000 years that would
be swell Norman Borlaug was supported by
the Rockefeller Foundation oil money the
sea for rice work is supported by the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
computer money that's the century were
in and here to take us into it is Jane
Langdale
[Applause]
no pressure there then being introduced
in the same sentence as Bullock I'd like
to start off by thanking Charles Mann
who came to talk to me a couple of years
ago about the c4 Rice project when he
was writing an article on it and I was
explaining to him what a long-term
project it was and he said oh you don't
know long term until you know the long
now foundation said you should really
you know go and give a talk there and he
was the one who suggested to Stewart
that he invite me and I think thanks to
it very much for inviting me and it
thank you all for coming out on a Monday
night what a weird thing to do so what
I'm hoping to do over the next hour or
so is give it a general overview to some
of the problems approach some of the
problems we're approaching in
agriculture as we go forward in the next
3040 years and of course the thing
that's driving a lot of those problems
is as we know is the changing world
population so it's not a surprise to you
that the population is increasing in
this slide here just shows you that
where those increases are and
essentially the majority percentage-wise
in terms of current population are in is
in Africa but if we look at the total
population now 7.3 billion you know the
majority is in Asia and that's going to
stay the same and certainly for 2050
Asia and Africa are going to have the
majority of the human population there's
going to be some interesting changes
actually during this period so India's
going to take over from China is the
most populous country and actually
Nigeria is going to take over from the
US as the third most populated country
or at least that's the predictions so
we've got to feed this growing
population and some of you will have
read in various places about how much we
need to increase food production in
order to do that and you may have
noticed that there's kind of big
differences in some of those numbers
some people say it's 70 percent some
people say it's a hundred percent so I
just want to start with by showing you
where some of these numbers come from so
the the FAO the United Nations Food and
culture organization held a workshop in
2009 to try and predict how much food
would need to be produced in 2050 and
they based this on food and feed but not
considering biofuels and they said that
by 2050 we'd need to be able to produce
3 billion tons of cereals a year and
they base this on the fact that they
accounted for the fact that people would
have to have a 3,000 calorie a day
intake so if you take that 3 billion
tonnes and this was in 2009 when they
first produced this report they said
we'd need to increase by 70% by 2012
they'd revised that number down to 60%
and if you actually look at last year's
harvest which was actually a bumper half
to its harvest there were 2.5 billion
tons produced so that's only a 20%
increase required over this time period
which is 0.6 percent per annum so what's
the big deal we can do that we've been
doing that for a while but that's just
one estimate of how much food we're
going to need to produce and it also
doesn't in take into account competing
land use for biofuels but here's another
way that food production estimates have
been brought about and this is based on
a correlation between essentially
per-capita GDP in a country and the
calories demanded by each individual in
that country and so in the most
economically advanced countries you will
see here in the red then the calorie
demand per person is 8,000 a day and
that's way above what the FAO have based
their estimates on and so what this
study did was essentially put all of the
economic groups on this graph and then
extrapolated based on previous economic
growth where these different economies
would be in 2050 and then drew a line
across how many calories they would be
they would be demanding and and those
estimates we need to double food
production if by any chance all the
economies reach the same level as the
group a then we
would have to increase food production
by a hundred and seventy five percent so
you can see from those examples that
there's a big range in what people think
we need to do and what we might have to
do and that there's also clearly quite a
lot of guesswork in the predictions but
regardless of whether it's twenty
percent or a hundred and seventy five
percent let's just look at where we are
with production and supply so this this
sorry production and utilization this
graph here shows you in the oranges
production since 2005 and his yellow is
utilization and then the gray bars are
closing stocks it's generally considered
that we need 30% of production in stock
for global food security and you can see
that last year again we have this bumper
year this is the the combined cereal
supply of wheat rice and maize across
the world and you can see that there was
still six hundred million tons in stocks
so it's looking okay what's the problem
but of course then when we look at
undernourishment across the world we've
still got 800 million people
undernourished and so even though the
production side looks healthy the actual
reality is not at all and so this is
this map shows you the darker the red
the greater the percentage of the
population that are undernourished and
so this is not a new problem that we
can't get food to where it's needed most
but we do need to be thinking for the
future how we're going to increase food
production particularly in Asia and
Africa given that those are the areas
where most of the population increase is
going to occur so one of the things we
can start by doing is thinking about
yield gaps so the difference between
what the theoretical maximum yield of a
crop is and what farming actually
attains with that crop and what these
maps show for both maize and rice is
where 75% of attainable yield is
achieved and that's in green and I
apologize to those who are green
at kelabra and i tried to find these
maps in other colors and they didn't
exist so short of drawing them myself
but I will point out 75% attainable
yields are achieved in North America and
in Europe for maize and a little bit of
South America and for rice it's pretty
much only China that reaches those 75%
yields so the first thing to think about
when we want to think about increasing
production is how can we close those
yield gaps in these other areas and the
blue shows where both nutrient and
irrigation is limiting and affecting
those yield gaps so what I want to do is
for the next few minutes is just go
through three of the most essential
inputs for crops and think about what
other limitations what are the real
challenges for the future and what can
plant science do to address some of
those issues and so the the three I'm
going to talk about our water phosphorus
and nitrogen the other one in the NPK
and fertilizer potassium I'm not going
to talk about it but we can talk about
it in questions if you like because I
don't see it as a such an immediate
problem so let's start with water I
don't think I need to stress in stress
how important water is in California not
least because the cab driver yesterday
spent the whole of the journey from the
airport to downtown telling me how
wonderful the rain was so I I realized
that you guys appreciate the importance
of water but let's have a look at the
global water deficits as they are or
were over the last ten years or so and
so what this map here is showing and
again apologies that it's green and red
is what's known as blue water scarcity
so green water is what comes out of the
sky and it's absorbed in the soil blue
water is what's in all the freshwater
reserves we have around the world so in
the rivers the aquifers the basins and
anywhere that's red here that's
Australia most of India a little bit of
China a bit of Africa certainly Central
America
is severely depleting its water reserves
so it's using more water than it's
essentially being able to put back in
and you can see that somewhere like
South Africa also in the yellow zone is
essentially starting to run out of water
reserves and so what does that mean for
a country like South Africa when it gets
its worst drought for a century which is
what's happening right now this is a
picture the Reuters picture taken just a
couple of weeks ago of a maze field in
South Africa so what is South Africa
doing to address this it's relaxing it's
GM import regulations and so South
Africa grows GM corn but it has quite
strict regulations on how much it can
import and it's relaxing those
regulations right now so that it can get
enough food for people to eat and that's
basically what we've been doing with
water for a while now so this map here
shows you where water is moving around
the world so there's a huge amount of
water going from the u.s. to Mexico
there's a huge amount going from the
u.s. into Japan and each of these arrows
the thickness of the arrow depict the
volume of water moving across and so
this is essentially a lot of this is
soybean being moved around the world but
this is the way we're dealing with it at
the moment we're essentially moving
crops to where they need to go but I
don't think it's orchestrated in any way
nobody's sitting there and saying okay
we can move this from here to there and
that will save water in this country and
you can see that because some of the the
red are the importers the UK is a is a
water importer that's hard to fathom
it's easy to fathom that Saudi Arabia
and Algeria a water importers maybe it's
not so easy to fathom why Japan's a
water importer either but there is no
strategic overview of where the water's
moving but serendipitously at the moment
it appears as though by doing this 4
percent of the we're saving about 4
percent of the blue water supplies by
moving things around from areas
there's rain-fed agriculture to areas
where they would other bye otherwise be
depleting reserves but it still doesn't
quite compute to me because two of those
countries that were in severe water
deficit India and Australia are water
exporters so this can't go on it can't
last and so one of the things we need to
think about is is what can plant science
do to assist with this and I think
there's reason for optimism here I think
you know there's a lot of work going on
on developing drought resistant crops
and this is an example of a rice variety
that was developed by the International
Rice Research Institute in the
Philippines to be drought resistant and
it's grown it's growing throughout India
it has a very respectable yield and
under drought circumstances it has a
much better yield than than other
varieties and there's also a lot of work
going on in terms of trying to work out
the basic biological processes
underlying the the rehydration of what
are known as resurrection plants so
things like tumbleweeds that can
essentially completely dry out and then
when they get water they'll essentially
come back to life and so there is hope
that plant science will have a lot to
contribute to this but that's not my
field and it's not what I'm going to be
mainly talking about so we'll move on
what about phosphorus so you all realize
why you need water you're all sitting
there some of you drinking water when
you get thirsty and your body needs
water water is essential for life you
perhaps don't realize why phosphorus is
so essential so phosphorus is a highly
reactive element it's used in matches as
the igniter but other than that as an
element a pure element it's not much
fair it's not found in nature but in
cells it's absolutely crucial for life
and it's crucial for life because
phosphorus is a component of DNA and so
DNA has the code is coded with these
four nucleotides as they called the ATGC
but
backbone of DNA is comprised of
phosphate and so no phosphate no DNA no
genes and also phosphate is required for
this innocuous-looking molecule here
called ATP which has three phosphate
groups on it and this is the battery of
all cells
you can't run a car on a flat battery
and you can't run a cell without ATP and
you can't make ATP without phosphorus so
no phosphorus no plant life no human
life phosphorus is essential for life so
where does it come from
well phosphorus is a essentially it's
mined from phosphate rock there's
nothing in the atmosphere so it's a
finite resource it's mined there our
reserves around various countries and
they'll come into that in a minute
90% of the phosphate rock that's mind is
destined for the food chain and it gets
out it's made into phosphate fertilizer
gets fed onto crops it gets fed into
animals and into ourselves and then in
theory what should happen is it should
go back into the land to complete the
cycle but that's not what not is not
what's happening at least 80% of
phosphate is being lost in this cycle
and it's primarily being lost into water
and it's being lost in the mining
process and it's being lost in the
farm-to-fork process and this can't go
on there is only a finite supply we
can't stop break it we have to stop
breaking the cycle we have to get that
phosphate back onto the land and one of
the reasons this is urgent
is because we're running out and so this
was the amount of rock extracted in 2015
there's three major countries that have
the phosphate reserves at the moment
China Morocco in the United States China
has a hundred and thirty five percent
export tax on its phosphate at the
moment to prevent any of it leaving the
country it realizes what an important
resource is the u.s. is actually
importing rock from
Rocko to make its phosphate fertilizer
rather than using its own reserves the
estimates are that there's only 25 years
left of the US reserves
so where are most of the reserves
essentially in Morocco 72% of the
reserves are in Morocco and the total
reserves are 69 billion tons now if you
divide that by that there's 300 years
left that's the best estimate but in
fact the quality of the phosphate rock
is deteriorating the amount of phosphate
mined per kilogram of rock is reduced in
the lower quality Rock and so in reality
it's probably let's say a hundred years
left so we can't keep going the way
we're going we've got to get phosphate
back into the land and we've got to
think more carefully about how we're
applying the inorganic phosphate
fertilizer that we're putting on so
let's just have a look at that as to
where the phosphate fertilizers being
applied most abundantly and the darker
blue means the more phosphates being put
on and you can see here it's basically
China Northern Europe and northern US
and it's not needed in the qualities in
the quantities that it's being put on in
all of those areas and essentially there
needs to be more precision in the amount
that's put on and the reason for that is
that when you add phosphate inorganic
phosphate fertilizer to the land then it
goes on in a form that is soluble and
the plant can take that soluble form up
but within two to three weeks that
phosphate is normally adsorbed or
retained by binding to other molecules
in the soil and that 80% then becomes
unavailable for plants so it's in the
soil but the plants can't use it and so
really we need to be getting to a point
where the phosphates being put on at the
levels at which only that amount 20% is
used and it's used in those first couple
of weeks we need more precision in the
phosphate application but what can
plants
answers do if anything about helping to
retrieve some of this insoluble
phosphate well here there is there is
hope because we know that plants behave
differently if they are adapted to low
phosphate regimes so here's just a
schematic that's just showing a plant
with half of its root system showing
what happens in a in a low phosphate
environment and half in a high phosphate
environment in a high phosphate
vironment that's the the roots will be
you'll have the primary root here and
you'll get some laterals coming out and
then they'll go down into the soil and
the roots that go down will have root
hairs that help essentially acquire the
nutrients but they won't have many in
contrast if you have a plant that's
adapted to low phosphorus then it will
be sending out more of its roots into
the topsoil where there's more of the
soluble phosphate to take up and the
roots that go down will have more root
hairs and these root hairs are
effectively excreting chemicals that
help to break down the phosphate that's
there and thereby increasing the uptake
of phosphate into this plant and another
key thing is that fungal associations
with plants so called micro Rises allow
the fungus to spread out into the soil
and increase the foraging capacity that
the plant has access to to pull more
phosphate up and what we know and
there's a number of labs working on this
including Jonathan Lynch's whose image
this is from Penn State we know the
sorts of genes that are involved in
changing that root architecture making
plants have more root hairs and so there
are a number of groups around the world
who are working at trying to change root
architecture so that it maximizes the
foraging capacity of plants so I think
this hope for plant science to help
retrieve phosphates that are currently
locked up in the soil but it's not going
to help the overall issue
which is we've got to get more phosphate
back into the land and probably the only
way we're going to do that is to start
recycling human sewage back onto land to
get the phosphate back in my opinion
let's move on to nitrogen then nitrogen
is a gas as you can see here from this
there's a bubbling vat of liquid
nitrogen here and nitrogen is a gas so
it's in the atmosphere so there's
there's more hope there's more of around
it's not a finite resource and nitrogen
too is absolutely essential for life and
it's essential for life for a different
reason these circles here depict the
amino acids that are the building blocks
of all proteins in all human cells and
if you look in every single one here
there's the chemical formula for the
amino acid and every single one has
nitrogen in it so no nitrogen no amino
acids no proteins no life so we need
nitrogen the nitrogen cycle is a little
more complex than the phosphate cycle
because it involves the activity of a
number of bacteria and so bizarre about
80% of the atmosphere is nitrogen so
there's a lot of it lightning can
immediately convert it into nitrate
which is the compound that plants take
up in the soil and there are
denitrifying bacteria in the soil that
will convert it back into atmospheric
nitrogen there are also as some of you
will be aware nitrogen fixing bacteria
that interact with the roots of some
plants and can take atmospheric nitrogen
convert it into ammonia and then with
various conversions why nitrifying
bacteria goes into nitrate and plants
take it up so there's quite a healthy
cycle here and get nitrogen through to
ammonia through to nitrate goes into
plants plants go into the animals we get
decay coming back into ammonia so it all
looks good for nitrogen or it would all
look good for nitrogen if it wasn't for
the fact that we're messing it up by
taking behavior process and taking
atmospheric nitrogen and converting it
into ammonia for
iliza so in a way even though this cycle
is healthy we've broken this one as well
as breaking the phosphate one by
producing masses amount of this and
putting it onto the land and you're all
familiar with the effects of runoff of
nitrogen and nutrient so let's look
again at where the global nitrogen
balances and you can see China green
here is where there's an excess of
nitrogen China India northern Europe
northern US and a bit of Central America
actually too much nitrogen going on the
land not needed greater need for
precision precision and in the areas
where we really need it in Africa
there's a deficiency and so again we
need to be thinking more about how we
can get more nitrogen into the soils
that actually need it and here there is
a long term prospect and it's based on
those nitrogen fixing microbes that I
mentioned a minute ago so plants such as
clover and beans and peas have what are
called symbiotic associations so
beneficial to both a microbe and to the
plant with both bacteria and with fungi
and so with bacteria they form an
association that results in the
formation of nodules on the leaf and
with fungi they form associations that
known as we've known as Mike ERISA in
which it effectively extends the root
system and what's known about how these
interactions are initiated is quite
revealing because it turns out so these
this here depict cells in the root here
the plant releases compounds that the
bacteria or the fungi recognize they're
different compounds but the principles
the same there's a signal going out from
the plant that the bacteria or the
fungus recognizes and once the bacteria
or the fungus has recognized that signal
it sends a response
another molecular signal back to the
plant and that initiates this symbiotic
reaction interaction
whereby the microbe provides the plant
with nitrogen and the planet provides
the microbe with carbon and so if every
plant could be manipulated so that it
had an association or was able to form
an association with one of these
microbes then it would be able to fix
his own nitrogen and this is a project
that is being led by Giles Oldroyd at
the John Innes Center it's another Bill
and Melinda Gates funded project called
Enza engineering nitrogen symbiosis for
Africa and what they're trying to do is
engineer cereals so that they're capable
of making these symbiotic relationships
with microbes and thus to be able to fix
their own nitrogen which is great it's
really fantastic if they can do this
however if they do this then the plants
may not be able to provide the carbon
unless we can increase the rate at which
the plants can produce carbon and so
this will only work if plants are able
to produce more carbon and to do that
we've got to harness the Sun and so
start off here with just thinking about
what yield is in a plan yield is
effectively solar energy of which
there's plenty of which we can't control
time's the interception efficiency the
efficiency with which a plant can
actually harvest that energy so if a
plant's got a leaf that's going like
that it's not going to harvest much of
the sun's energy it's got a leaf that's
going like that it's got a flat surface
to harvest the energy so the
interception efficiency is one of the
key factors of yield the second factor
is conversion efficiency with what
efficiency is the electromagnetic energy
from the Sun converted to biochemical
energy in the form of sugars and the
third one is the partitioning efficiency
to what extent are the sugars that are
produced
actually partitioned in the grain
because if they stay in the leaves
that's not going to assist with yield so
that's essentially the yield equation
and traditional breeding has selected on
these factors in the following way so
ninety-nine percent of the theoretical
maximum interception efficiency has been
cheap ninety two percent of the maximum
partitioning efficiency has been
achieved but only thirty four percent of
the conversion efficiency has been
achieved so if we want to aim at
improving yield this is where we've got
to focus and this is essentially
photosynthesis so this is the simplest
form of photosynthesis carbon dioxide
plus water in the presence of light
gives you carbohydrates and oxygen and
those that reactional those reactions
takes place in chloroplasts or at least
in higher plants and this is a this is a
electron microscopic image of a
chloroplast and you can see that it's a
membrane-bound organelle and each of
these dark patches are regions of very
highly dense membranes with large
surface areas and then these white blobs
are the starch that's produced as the
product of photosynthesis so what
happens is that in these membranous
regions where there's high surface area
then light splits water produces oxygen
and then the hydrogen atoms that are
released that are highly energetic go
through a series of reactions in these
membranes that result in the production
of our little friend ATP the cell's
battery so these light reactions provide
the energy for the next phase of
photosynthesis which is where carbon
dioxide is fixed into carbohydrates and
it gets deposited in the starch grains
so what's so inefficient about this
process splits water produces energy
the energy is used to make the sugars
well it falls down with a protein called
Rubisco and this is a depiction of a
self the black is the cell the green is
the chloroplast within the cell and what
happens is that co2 carbon dioxide is
fixed by this enzyme rubisco into a
sugar that has three carbons
hence c3 photosynthesis and the majority
of plants are c3 photosynthesizing
plants so they take co2 fix it with
Rubisco into a three carbon compound
that then goes off to produce
carbohydrate Rubisco is the most
abundant protein on the planet fifty
percent of the leaf nitrogen is Rubisco
so a lot of that nitrogen fertilizer is
going into Rubisco the problem with
Rubisco is that in addition to fixing
co2 into these three carbon compounds
that go on to make sugars it interacts
with oxygen and when it interacts with
oxygen it only forms one of these three
carbon compounds and it produces this
other compound which is toxic to the
plant and so the plant then has to go
through a detoxification process to
actually get rid of this toxic molecule
and by doing that it decreases the
efficiency of photosynthesis and so
whilst Rubisco is clearly essential for
life it's also very inefficient and so
one of the goals of this next project
ripe realizing increased photosynthetic
efficiency is to try and engineer
Rubisco to be more efficient why can't
it just be engineered so that it doesn't
see oxygen so that it only sees carbon
dioxide and then you wouldn't have to go
through this wasteful detoxification
process and so this is another gates
funded project
and we're all working together answer
ripe and see for rice to maximize
efficiency these guys are working
primarily on trying to increase
components of c3 photosynthesis
including trying to engineer Rubisco so
that it doesn't react with oxygen we're
taking a slightly different view and
it's driven by what we see in evolution
evolution has not improved the
efficiency of Rubisco however c4 plants
have effectively got around the problem
so here again is that c3 reaction co2
being fixed by Rubisco but there's
oxygen hanging around that right net
might mess it up so what if c4 plants
done they've done this and I'll just
take a minute here so essentially what
they've done is they've split
photosynthesis between two cells so in a
c3 plant this happens in all of the
cells in the leaf in a c4 plant there's
two different types of photosynthetic
cells which for now we're going to call
an outer cell and an inner cell with the
outer being towards the outer edge of
the leaf and therefore the warning
contact with carbon dioxide and oxygen
you could see in the inner cell this
last bit of the reaction is exactly the
same as this so fundamentally at the end
of the day co2 gets fixed by Rubisco
into three carbon compound and into
carbohydrates but there's all this other
stuff first and this other stuff is
effectively a turbocharger it's there to
concentrate carbon dioxide and the way
it does that is in this outer cell
carbon dioxide enters and it's fixed by
an enzyme that is blind to oxygen it's
totally insensitive to oxygen it doesn't
care whether the oxygens out here or
even here sat right on top of it it
NORs it's a very inefficient carbon
fixer and it's fixed into a four carbon
compound hence C for photosynthesis and
that compound is then shuttled into this
inner cell type where the carbon dioxide
is released from it and by doing that
what you're doing is concentrating co2
at the site of Rubisco in addition by
doing this in the inner cell you're
keeping Rubisco away from oxygen so it's
a double win you're effectively
increasing the efficiency with which
photosynthesis takes place I'll come
back to some of this detail later you'll
be pleased to hear but for now I'm gonna
leave it at that and say well why would
we be thinking about the c-4 solution
when it's so complicated surely those
guys who are thinking about engineering
Rubisco to ignore oxygen must be on a
better a better track but see fors
evolved over 60 times during Lampang
evolution and this is just what's known
as a phylogram that essentially every
single line is a flowering spoke plant
species and every red line is a c4
species so not only has c4 evolved over
60 times its evolved in all sorts of
areas of the tree in diverse families
and it all happened about 25 to 35
million years ago so even though what I
just showed you on the previous slide
looked incredibly complex it seems to
have happened over and over again in
independent families so how difficult
can it be
so let's see what's so good about it
so c4 gives you better yield this is a
filled-in at the International Rice
Research Institute in the Philippines a
few years ago and they planted rice in
the front and maize at the back they
planted it around the same time and it
was subject to the same environmental
conditions and you can see very clearly
that even if we don't consider grain
yield the biomass produced by this maize
crop at the back is much greater than
that produced by the rice crop and when
the grain yield was considered you can
see again that the maize had much
greater yield in terms of grain maze is
a c4 plant rice is a c3 plant so one
hypothesis is that the reason this
produces more biomass is because it's c4
and I give sometimes I show this slide
at schools and they go but but it could
just because it's maize it might not be
because it's c4 but this in the middle
here is a weed and it's a c4 weed this
weed has not been selected for
productivity or for yield and you can
see again that the biomass produced by
this weed is much greater than the c3 so
I think we can safely say that c4 crops
give better yield than c3 they also have
better radiation use efficiency so what
this graph here shows you is the
standing dry weight at harvest so again
effectively the biomass and the length
of the growing season so how long have
these plants been exposed to light and
the triangles they're all c4 plants and
the circles are all c3 plants and you
can see that the longer you leave it the
more light it harvests then the more
biomass you get but you can also see
that the that slope is much steeper if
you have a c4 plant regardless of which
3/4 plant it is so they use light more
efficiently they also use nitrogen more
efficiently so on this graph here what
you've got is how the rate of carbon
dioxide fixation against the leaf
nitrogen content
yellow is c4 green is c3 and essentially
what you can see is that for less
nitrogen you get more co2 assimilation
and the reason for that is that because
c4 photosynthesis is more efficient only
about 30% of the leaf nitrogen is
Rubisco instead of 50% so it's a direct
relationship between how much Rubisco is
needed to carry out the photosynthesis
so less nitrogen less Rubisco still as
efficient and finally c4 plants have
better water use efficiency and this is
a slightly different way of looking at
this these are a bunch of different
species from a single genus of plants or
called Flo Varia and Flo very has
species that are c3 that are
intermediate between c3 and c4 and are
c4 and what you're looking at here is
the amount of co2 fixed per mole of
water
so in these c3 plants the dark green
here you essentially get 3 milli moles
of co2 fixed per mole of water but in
these c4 ones at this end you get twice
as much so you've got much better water
use efficiency in the CFU c4 plants so
the bottom line is that if you could
convert c3 to c4 in theory you could
increase yield by 50%
you would improve nitrogen use
efficiency and you could probably double
water use efficiency so why wouldn't you
do it
and this effectively is where the c-4
ricer project began and it began in 2006
when John Sheehy who was working at the
International Rice Research Institute
called a workshop for what was then the
remaining few people who knew anything
about c4 photosynthesis on the planet
and called us all into a room and said
now's the time we should be thinking
about whether or not we can convert c3
plants into c4 previously it had been an
impossible dream but technology had
moved on next generation sequencing
sequence lots of genomes you could now
finally transform rice which hadn't been
possible before hands he get genes
inserted into rice and he brought us all
together and they're essentially
scientists from twelve different
institutions around the world eight
different countries and we decided that
yes if it was going to happen now was
the time to to start it and this is the
map that we laid out it's been slightly
tweaked since then this is the updated
one and we figured that would take about
thirty years and that phase one should
be about building a toolkit could we get
all the bits and pieces together that we
needed to be able to insert genes into
rice to be able to think about which
genes to put in Phase two was what we
called proof of concept having got those
things put together could we actually at
least show some indication that we knew
what we were doing the third phase would
be a step back having done that you know
could we really understand mechanism in
c4 plants let alone engineer c3 the
fourth would be engineering and the
fifth would be breeding so step back you
don't even have to step back to imagine
this let's step back to 2006 you're
thinking of a 30 year project and you're
thinking about it in rice you're
thinking about it as a project for
developing countries where do you go for
money national funding agencies would
not fund something like this it's too
big it's too long-term and there's much
more urgent things that need funding in
terms of trying to keep home
institutions going when you're looking
at things like National Science
Foundation or they research Research
Council's in the UK so that's not going
to work
okay it's it's a project for developing
countries
what about overseas development agencies
they're not going to fund it they're too
busy putting money into what's needed
now zika ebola whatever the car
crisis's that's where their money's
going to be it's not going to go into
something like this what about the AG
biotech companies they're not going to
be interested they have no idea whether
there's going to be a product and they
are they're only going to invest if
there's definitely going to be a product
that's going to make money so we went to
the Gates Foundation and Gates funded
the first three phases we don't know
whether they'll fund anymore but what
they have done is they've de-risked the
project because we now are at a point
where I think it's going to work it's
still going to take a long time but
without their investment in the first
place and their vision to get behind
something like this it would never have
got off the ground so why did we choose
rice we could have picked any c3 plant
we could have picked wheat this as much
wheat grown as rice well partly because
it was initiated from the International
Rice Research Institute but rice is
really Asia's lifeline the if you look
at this graph here what you're looking
at is the percentage total calorie
intake in different countries and in
Asia as a whole so though the dots are
the across Asia average even now 30% of
the daily calories are in the form of
rice in Bangladesh it's still 70% of the
daily calorie intake from rice and 90%
of global production is in Asia last
year was the year the highest year of
rice moving around the country and there
was still only 9% of the world's
production was exported 140 million rice
farmers in Asia and most of them on
small farms and their yield average is
about 4.6 tonnes per hectare and if we
look at projections for the future that
needs to increase rapidly and the
current breeding programs are getting
less than 1% yield
so rice is extremely important for Asia
and let's look at this supply and demand
so this is a very similar graph
what I showed you earlier for the global
cereal production and there if you
remember there was a nice healthy
difference between production
utilization and there was a nice healthy
stop level that wasn't being depleted
that's not the case here so here we've
got utilization in orange production in
blue and you'll see that last year
production dipped below utilization and
so the stocks had to be drawn down and
also here the stocks are not at the 30%
level that you would like to see them at
and so there is a great need to increase
yields in rice in Asian rice growing
areas and if we look at that how it's
grown in Asia on the basis of land area
50% is irrigated but a quite significant
proportion is rain fed and if we compare
the yield of irrigated versus Rainford
it's quite substantial so on the
irrigated the average yield is about 6
tonnes per hectare in the u.s. here you
get about 9 tons per hectare hybrid rice
in China will get about 15 tonnes per
hectare but that's where they're
throwing all that nitrogen and phosphate
at it and then the rain fed rice is
maximum to two and a half tons per acre
so if anything could be done to improve
the rain fed rice at least it would make
a huge difference both in Asia and
Africa and the bottom line when you
consider all of the things take all
things into account such as reduced land
use is that the number of people
dependent on a hectare of rice producing
land in Asia in 2010 was 27 by 2050
it's got to be 43 which happens to be a
50% increase so why wouldn't you try and
convert ce3 rice into a c4 plant because
in theory it can increase rice yield by
50% so
what do we need to do we need to take
the c3 plant we need to change the leaf
anatomy we need to change the
biochemistry do a bit of fine-tuning and
we'll have a c4 plant no problem
so let's come back to this slide which
you love that when I put it up first
time
so here's c3 here's c4 the biochemistry
of c4 was first discovered 50 years ago
and we've known all of the genes that
encode all the required enzymes and the
transporters since at least the late
1980s so not a big deal we know what
genes were dealing with but everything
in blue here with a square around it is
an enzyme that needs to be modified so
that it only functions in one of these
two cell types every dot is a
transporter protein that is responsible
for moving products out of the
chloroplast or inter from oneself into
the other and so there's quite a lot of
genes that need to be modified to
achieve this but we do know what they
are so that's good contrast that with
this so here's a rice leaf and it's
you've got a vein here with a ring of
cells around it which have no
chloroplasts in it and then you've got a
whole bunch of cells in between with
chloroplasts in depicted down here
schematically and then you've got
another vein and all of these light blue
cells here are carrying out c3
photosynthesis Rubisco is fixing co2 if
you compare that to a maize leaf which
is carrying out c4 photosynthesis then
hopefully you can see a few differences
one is these cells around the veins are
packed full of chloroplasts and the
veins are much closer together so the
maximum you have is a vein one of these
which I'm now going to give you the name
of the inner bundle sheath cell then a
Mesa fill cell another musical cell and
a bundle sheath cell so a very different
to me and Anatomy that is the way it is
because essentially it's these pairs of
cells that are interacting for the sea
for biochemistry we have no idea what
regulates the difference between this
and this anatomy we had no idea what
genes were responsible it started the
project we're getting there now and I'll
tell you a little bit about that minute
but what we decided we do the start was
try and get see for biochemistry in a
module in the rice leaf just next to the
veins let's just ignore the fact for the
moment that the veins aren't close
enough together to be a true c4 let's
see if we can get the biochemistry in
these two cells and to do that all we
need to do is switch Rubisco plus three
other genes on in this cell switch
Rubisco off in this cell and switch
seven other genes on and we know what
the genes are as I said but I just want
to put in here at this point that to my
knowledge the most elaborate GM plant
transgenic plant that's been made today
is Golden Rice and it has two genes in
it so we need to modify at least ten
genes how do we do that well we start by
we can insert genes into rice we start
with a seed and we grow it on a media
that induces the rice to to produce this
sort of mushy looking tissue and these
are essentially naive cells they don't
know whether they should be a root or a
chute and so you can catch them in their
naive phase and put a piece of DNA in
them and then they take that DNA up and
this is just an example of a gene that's
been put in that induces a blue color so
we can see what's happening and then we
put these lumps of naive tissue with the
gene we've put into them back onto a
different media regenerates and you get
rice plant and that takes about five
months
and then what you can do given that
we're trying to get ten genes in and
we've just put one in here is oh sorry
step back so one of the key things is
that I said that we had to be able to
regulate which sells the genes were
switched on in
so some genes had to be on in the inner
cells and some had to be on in the outer
cells which means we need switches that
act in those cells and that it was
actually part of the first phase where
we were developing our toolkit how are
we going to find switches that will only
work in one cell or the other and I'm
just going to show you that we did find
switches and we I'm just showing here
the switch is driving again that gene
that gives the blue color so here's a
switch that only works in the outer
cells you can see that the inner cells
around the vein are clear and here's a
switch that only works in the inner
cells so we were able to identify pieces
of DNA that would act as switches to
switch genes on in the Wrights right
cell type and at the right time and so
having done that we started to introduce
the genes one by one and then started a
crossing program and that is so this is
just an example here with four genes and
you start with your four lines and you
cross them together and if you cross
gene one with gene two a quarter of the
progeny will have both and then you
cross this to this and a sixteenth will
have four and by this time you're going
nuts because they're all over the
they're not being targeted to any
specific place in the genome so they're
all segregating independently and the
numbers get way out of hand and you've
only got four at this point and we're
aiming for 10 but we have managed to
make a line with five of these genes in
and there is some evidence that it has
changed metabolism we're not quite sure
how and we're in the process of
investigating that but meanwhile and
this is one of the the sort of lessons
of these long term projects meanwhile
technology's moved on and had we known
what we know now when we started this
project we wouldn't even start
this way so even though we will use
these plants that we've generated which
have the five genes stacking them to try
and understand something about the
biology that's not the way we're going
to go we've got to start again and the
reason we can start again is due to the
advent of synthetic biology and genome
engineering and I've just drawn this
very simple slide here to show you
exactly what we're we're doing now so we
have libraries of parts we have switches
we have genes that encode enzymes we
have genes that encode transporters and
some of you will have heard drew Andy
talked about BioBricks it's exactly the
same principle you can click these
things together in any which way you
want and so very easily we can make a
construct that has all of these genes on
it so instead of inserting them one by
one we can now insert six at a time and
not only can we insert six at a time we
can decide where they're going to go so
we can I can't see the bottom of my
slide now I've just clicked on so let's
say we want to target to this region
here with the light green and the olive
green next to it essentially we
introduce these this piece of DNA which
has got all of these switches and
enzymes on it at the same time as
introducing some molecular scissors the
molecular scissors will cut this DNA the
targeted region of the genome here and
allow us to insert that fragment and now
we have a plant that's got six genes and
if we cross it to another one that's got
six genes a quarter of those progeny
will have 12 genes and that's much more
manageable so we're going back now and
starting to reintroduce the biochemistry
through this better method and there's
no doubt as we go forward for the next
20 years the same things going to happen
we're going to hit something come across
something that makes it much quicker and
it's going to be quicker to start again
then keep going with what we're doing so
meanwhile well that's going on let's
just come back to this to end the talk I
said we knew nothing about how
this Anatomy develops in maze so how can
we possibly think about how to engineer
it in rice and that's something that
we've been working on over the past
seven or eight years and the way we
approached this was to capitalize on the
fact that if you look in a maze plant if
you look at the regular leaves which we
call foliar leaves they have the c4
anatomy the closed vein spacing these
two photosynthetic cell types but if you
look in the leaves around the ear so the
husk leaves that you shuck off every
time you eat an ear of corn they have
these this intermediate Anatomy whereby
there's a bit of c4 like around the vein
but then there's still lots of cells in
between so the anatomy in terms of the
vein spacing is more c3 like than c4 and
if you look at the timing which they
develop so if you take this that you're
looking at the Mattocks of cross
sections of the leaf at very early
stages in development the two leaves the
foliar and the husk look the same you
have these very immature cells and you
get veins starting to form and then
cells forming around them a bit later in
development there's a clear difference
so there's a stage at which the Leafs
developing where the key events are
happening when those veins are being put
in and knowing when this stage is
enabled us to take samples from all of
these different stages and essentially
get the sequence of every single gene
that was expressed in each of the
samples and by doing that we got a
database of 30,000 genes and we first
looked at it to see which genes are off
in husk and on in folia we refined that
slightly to say the ones that are on in
folia need to be on at the right time
they've got to be on at that time when
all the actions going on when those
extra veins are being
formed and that got us to 283 genes we
then spent much longer than we had doing
this analysis reading and thinking
trying to understand everything there
was to know about those 283 genes trying
to rationalize which ones we should
actually focus our attention on because
the next stage was going to be very
time-consuming and we got it down to 70
and with those 70 what we then did was
we did two things we turned them off in
maze by inserting trans genes to turn
them off and we asked the question when
we turn them off does the anatomy of the
maze leaf revert to look more like rice
if so we have a gene that has a role in
producing this Anatomy in maze we also
turn them on in rice and asked can we
convert this to this if the answer was
yes it doesn't mean necessarily that
that gene has a role in maze to develop
that Anatomy but who cares
it means we can use it to change the
anatomy in rice and doing that we're now
down to about 20 genes and we can
probably refine it over the next year or
so down to slightly lower number so
where are we we still have a challenge
we think for the anatomy we may have to
change the behavior of 12 genes for the
biochemistry about 10 and who knows for
the last bit but we're optimistic this
is the team we work very well together
you will see from the faces on this
slide that there are very few bar this
one here who are not going to be retired
by the time
20:39 comes and so really the team are
these guys here who are the young
students and the postdocs who work on
the project and I have never worked on a
project that has had so much interest
from young people students who want to
work on it and want to come and join us
and we need them we need at the more
hands and minds on this project the
faster we'll get to where we're going
and with that I will leave you with this
and thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
and I've been seeing a lot wrongly that
digital code is relatively easy to
reverse-engineer the bio code is
impossible to reverse engineer and
you're just proving that is not true you
can reverse engineer it yes first
question has come up from several people
so though we should go and do it a
little more deeply why right why rice my
guess both from the kind of demand
standpoint and from the is the plant
which is gonna be workable compared to
say wheat or something like that so rice
rice has a major advantage over wheat
and that is in terms of its genome
structure so rice has two copies of its
genome it's a diploid wheat has six so
if you're gonna try and engineer or
modify things in a in any background if
you're only battling against two
endogenous copies you're in a better
chance of winning the fight than
battling against six that doesn't mean I
mean there certainly are long term
aspirations to that if we can make it
work in rice then why not in wheat I
mean the same problems apply other food
crops besides racing we'd like to you
confirm we could we could do bali we
could do we could do any we could do
canola anything anything louia rodriguez
asks are there any downfalls of c4 over
c3 that are known and what are the sort
of I guess usage unknowns that might
emerge here so the downfalls this kind
of a so often I get asked this question
a slightly different way in terms of why
are there not more c4 plants if it's so
good why isn't everything about yeah so
so the answer is because there's a cost
so for every molecules carbon dioxide
that gets fixed in a c3 plant it uses
three of those ATP molecules three of
the battery charge whereas in a c4 plant
it uses five and that cost is worth it
in high temperature because in high
temperature dissolved oxygen effectively
is more likely to react with Rubisco and
make photosynthesis inefficient so it's
a balancing act in high temperature then
c4 definitely wins in low temperature it
doesn't so what we really need to do is
have an inducible temperature inducible
c4
so once we've learned that how to do c4
we need to get it all under a
temperature inducible switch so that as
the temperature goes up as c4 that goes
back to c3 temperature is going up with
global warming so the c4 plants going to
be more or less comfortable with global
warming and droughts and things like
that do you think more how much more
that much more Wow
I think that you can interpret that as
and I don't know here's a kind of a
nutrition question from Adam Flynn c3
plants at least judging by the list you
show it seemed to be richer
micronutrients are there any unintended
consequences downstream in relation to
the micronutrients in these plants I
think that list might have been skewed
by the fact that the c3 plants on it as
far as I remember weren't cereals and
cereal grains generally have this much
so you'll have a c4 plants with all the
micronutrients intact and summer I mean
I mean it it even with 20 genes my
prediction is that by the time we get to
it it'll just be one chunk of DNA that
goes in well that's interesting it's not
going to be doesn't matter where it is
so much we'll get it in and we'll get it
into a benign region of the genome where
it doesn't affect anything else and so
what that means if it's a single gene is
you can cross it to anything so you can
cross it out into all the different
varieties that are around at the moment
the high nutrient the drought resistant
the flood tolerant whatever it'll just
be one allele going one trait being
crossed in do you want to just add a
chromosome that has all this rational
coding on it that's a very interesting
question and the technology is not there
to be able to do that doesn't mean it
won't be if it comes that sounds like
something yeah so mmm you've talked
mainly about the c4 aspects which would
they have you know a whole bunch of
benefits can these things Rice's and
annual plans that right could it be made
perennial Rahl a dumb jock here was
asking the plant once harvest forever
yum you know I mean the ancestor of rice
was a perennial so domesticated rice was
a perennial but I guess that's I guess
my answer to that will be that's a
different set of questions and it'll
just be another trait in the toolbox
they'll have another 20 genes on it that
will just cross the two to
you know they did a wonderful case of
proving how relatively few genes may be
needed to get the structural impact and
then the mechanisms for the better
photosynthesis that's not that many
genes in terms of what CRISPR can do
these days I don't want to go on about
our woolly mammoth but George church's
move sixteen genes affecting for a
woolly mammoth traits into living
elephant cell line and they're there and
seem to be doing their job doesn't the
CRISPR cash now and the capability just
sort of open up your not so fiercely
limited to the number of genes that you
can mess with no that's absolutely true
and that's why you know we know for sure
we can get seven in at the same time
into rice at the moment I'm sure it'll
be more than that way more than that and
seaport and sorry CRISPR came along kind
of unexpectedly for everybody and it's
just you know there's thirty thousand
labs that are using CRISPR now do you
see that as the kind of trend that might
affect your 39 year timeline to make it
go quicker or just make it actually
plausible I think it will make it
plausible I think our biggest problem
with with the timeline is the you know
this whole synthetic biology idea you
know design test build design build test
even his our problem is the build takes
so long to make the transgenic lines
that work by the time we get to testing
you know and then go back to the
beginning it's a it's a much it's not a
yeast cell this is it's it's at least a
year for each cycle of that so when you
went from there was you know three
generations to get maybe forty from the
sort of breeding a sequence to screw it
let's do it all at once was that like a
hard shift in the whole process and a
bunch of people are out of work I mean
what happened some skills that you
developed a great expense or suddenly
worthless how's that process work out
when you
you know basically dese killing your own
capabilities if you move along that's
not an easy question to answer
there are certainly there's certainly
areas of the project that are no longer
attracting as many resources so that you
have young scientists showing up and
this is a fast-moving field in certain
extent you like presumably they you got
this kind of great combination of people
who've been focusing on c4 and on rice
for many decades now and also people
showing up able to grab whatever is the
current technology and sprint the
horizon with it
how's that intergenerational playing
playing out it's possible to achieve a
good balance because at the end of the
day we've got to go back into a rice
breeding program and places like Erie
are the people who are going to be doing
that so so I guess the way to say is
that the first couple of phases were
very much focused on being able to grow
lots of rice and do lots of screens very
labor-intensive required the right
growth conditions and they were focused
primarily at Erie this third phase we're
in is is essentially taking a step back
now and saying right we need to really
understand the genetics of what's
happening in maize so that we can
engineer and given all this new
technology we can do that a bit faster
and so the focus has shifted slightly
for this phase but it will undoubtedly
shift back was your understanding of
people are understanding maize all that
much better there must be some side
effect benefits for maize with that
understanding so that are the corn
people getting re excited by some of
this examination yeah I mean corn the
best thing you can do for corn is make
it nitrogen-fixing then cool people
would be very happy say more about that
well what the ideal would be a see for
nitrogen-fixing cereal not a all see for
nitrogen fixing cereals and what's your
guess
how many genes does it take to get those
things to be mutualistic with bacteria
and fungi I don't know what Charles is
current estimate is for the answer
project for the nitrogen but it's
probably bad the same 20
okay so we're headed choice I mean it's
not only greater efficiency in terms of
fertilizer is basically creating its own
fertilizer yeah so then we've only got
left with the phosphate problem then we
come back to human sewage a couple of
questions relate to well you know other
things happen what if you wind up with a
c4 rice that fixes its own nitrogen and
doesn't taste very good sure you read it
into so the lines were actually the
lines were actually trying to do the
manipulation of now you wouldn't want to
eat I mean he's a model line that comes
later
that comes later yeah because he
mentioned the way we're talking but
before this evening that Golden Rice of
about which there has been much hope in
much controversy the it sounded like it
at Irian IRI and the Philippines they
they got a Golden Rice that had the
extra ingredients that people were so
glad of but his yield went down how does
that happen what's the workaround for
that kind of unexpected and unwelcome
side effect well when essentially
whenever you make one of these
insertions there's a you don't just do
it once there's a number of lines you
can select from so having found that
they go back to another event and an
event is when you put a piece of DNA
into a plant and it inserts somewhere in
the genome that is an event you can take
the same piece of DNA insert it into the
same genome not the same individual but
same genome and it can go into a
different part in the genome that's a
different event so depending where it
lands in each event it may have
different knock-on effects to what the
point was
that won't happen we
CRISPR is your target it there
I've always wondered why is it called in
an event because it happened and
actually actually for the person who was
actually doing the experiment it
probably really wasn't about yes I see
another word for triumph yes
alexandros asks if you achieve all of
this how to get c4 rice into all the
fields that need it which is as we saw
the opening film vast quantities of
different peoples different lands
different soils different climates
different tastes and you've got one
mechanism how does it get out to the
variety how many varieties of rice are
there I think Erie has close to a
hundred thousand different varieties or
something right and how many of the
major of how many of the crop prices
that's our three thousand different
kinds okay they're not all thrown every
year but but essentially they I mean
Erie a really good at taking a new trait
and getting it very quickly into a large
range I mean not a hundred thousand all
in one go but a large range of different
varieties that are grown by upland
farmers lowland farmers maddie farmers
in in temperate in tropical and they
they have that system down really well
so as long as you as long as you have a
trait that is just at a single locus so
that it's not separating every time you
cross it then then that's what they
that's what they're brilliant at doing
so we could have a hundred thousand
varieties and see for rice apparently
many people have been asking about the
nine thousand number that was mentioned
there that we need just two thousand
what calories per day so the difference
between just enough I gather there's two
thousand was that going on in three
thousand three thousand and nine
thousand is that food wastage and some
it's partly food wastage but it's also
meat mmm okay because it's ten ten
kilograms of grain for one kilogram of
live cow his race fed to and not an
issue chris says that public health
officials obviously have issues with
human waste on crops what do you tell
them to ease their fears if any of this
because this whole cycling of well they
don't actually see so believe it up when
I was thinking about this I actually did
some reading about sewage treatment
plants which was a bit bizarre but
there's quite a few particularly in this
country but also in the UK that have a
process to make something called
struvite pellets that is actually
recycling human waste into pellets that
will act as slow-release phosphate
pellets but the predictions are that it
will only provide about three million
tonnes of the 24 million tonnes needed
annually but it's happening now in
various sewage plants across the u.s.
right now you have struvite facilities
so we're already eating pre eaten food
[Laughter]
reminds me of a sign where my father's
in toilet or summer cottages said do not
put anything in the toilet unless you
beaten it first we could edit you guys
haven't even begun to deal with the GMO
controversy because your ears out deonda
you think it'll be basically gone by the
time see for rice hits the market what
do you think people be saying I don't
want any c4 rice in my country or my
food because there's probably something
wrong with it who knows it flip-flops
doesn't it I mean you guys used to
embrace it fully and now you don't and
in Europe you still cannot import any GM
crop for human consumption you can find
a more consumption who knows I mean as
an aside 70% of the animal feed in the
UK comes from GM soy bean from Brazil we
pretend not to notice or is there a
specific no animal feeds fine but it
used to come from Romania but when
Romania joined the EU they could no
longer grow GM soy bean so now it gets
shipped from Brazil and the EU pays
Romania subsidies because their farmers
can't grow the crop
I sense there's other efficiency
inefficiencies in the process than just
the difference between c3 and c4 is the
screaming need for food and for higher
yield food widely enough understood that
people are actually trying to cut out
stupid problems like the additive food
wastage problems and so on I not yet
where there's no need right but the
South Africa example I showed you know
as soon as there's a need things get
relaxed a little more down in South
Africa so they're having prayer having a
serious Drive right now and so that's
seriously worried that they can't feed
the population so they have relaxed or
they're talking and I don't know whether
they've even agree this was just a week
or so ago talking about relaxing the
import regulations so that they can get
GM food from elsewhere probably hear
some of those stockpiles and because
they have regulations about how much can
actually be stored GM food they grow it
what's the profit there's some
convoluted system where they can't store
more than a certain amount but they're
they're considering and I don't whether
it's been decided yet relaxing that so
that food can come in so the bottom line
is if people are really hungry
then principles go to hell haha we might
have to edit that this one please
so you can almost sort of map where that
transition is going to occur from where
the hunger is likely to occur and people
just say screw it and let's do it yeah
do it whatever way works pragmatism
replaces ideologies when that's the
bertolt brecht line about food first
then morals you've been at this how long
didn't anybody tell you it's rude to ask
a lady no sorry the long now foundation
if you have been at you know less than
10 years are you talking about seafloor
ISIL how long I've been working on how
to develop how long on rice and sea for
rice yeah since 2002 be first got
funding 2008 that's what we kicked off
and you expect when little people here
probably not including me I'll get to
eat see for rice music 2040 2040 at
which point the world population will be
on the order of eight or nine billion I
guess and then you get to the
interesting issue of Rice's as I
understand a very labor-intensive
problem there's a lot of people mostly
women out there just whole day long in
the muck planning and reaping there's
lots of little children with with pieces
of string they pull like this to keep
the birds off particularly in Benari in
those rice terraces that's how they keep
the birds off the kids just pull a
string backwards and forth the strain is
making the keeping the birds awake so
they're doing instead of going to school
people are moving to the cities and this
is huge areas of rural countryside in
some cases in mountain countryside it
sounds
incredibly laborious boring in life
consuming so where do we get the people
to grow all the c4 rise mechanization is
something that's already starting to be
introduced in rice farming in fact
though it's actually leading to rice
straw for the first time and people are
trying to decide what we use this for
rice straw because where they are
bringing in harvesters there's now straw
to be dealt with so there's a new use I
mean my assumption is near frankly that
robots will take over agriculture by and
large it's already happening to
something that some precision
agriculture as it's called in the
Midwest is you know that you've turned
them combine loose in the fields and
it's sensing the soil and the moisture
and the weather and putting just the
right seed and just right fertilizer
together kind of on its own there may be
a guy in the cab but he's online having
a social day
rice is not exactly big flat fields
largely I mean many of them are not so
do you see just more and more
sophisticated robots to manage this or
are you are people working on making
rice less of something that requires
children to jiggle it to keep the birds
away or there requires in those
quantities of women hand planning these
things or collecting the rice the son I
mean certainly the planting now I mean
the in Asia they haven't got to this the
point where they're planting it but
aeroplanes like you do in California but
mechanization in terms of planting the
seedlings out and also harvesting is
starting to come in are some nations
more eager to move ahead with basically
GM rice and eventually c4 rice than
others you mentioned Bangladesh
Bangladesh is yeah Bangladesh is very
keen so Bangladesh is trying the new
golden rice variety Bangladesh has also
been very they've adopted the BT brinjal
leaf I've got too many words in my head
no BT brinjal which is aubergine which
is eggplant which alright brinjal so
they're very they've adopted that and
it's it's their their trial that they've
got a research institute that's trialing
the Golden Rice and they're very keen to
do so and you can see why they're you
know essentially going yes give it to me
they're 70% calories come from rice they
want to be able to expand their food
production and diversity so they're
willing to go with it so once again the
hunger draws the technology to it
oh so it's one of many South Asian
nations or others paying attention to
what Bangladesh does early yeah she
isn't India is interesting because you
know they have bt cotton and they've
completely embraced that right as far as
i know they don't have any other GM
crops approved at the moment and china
is doing what direction
and all this china's kind of dithering
uh-huh and you have a expectation it'll
go one way or the other well do you see
I'm probably know various Chinese
scientists who are working on we have
right yeah and seriously the question of
government be enthusiastic around people
being enthusiastic not enough scientist
what's what what drives this whole
scientists I think I honestly don't know
I honestly don't know in terms of the
complexity of China Chinese politics and
and what they're doing with the GM well
that I see is amazing stuff coming very
slowly we love slow revolutions around
thank you for doing
[Applause]
[Music]
you